talk about the strange music tour rules
yeah strange music is wild but it works
really well for me because i'm a super
organized like yeah you're not [ __ ]
a wild druggie so yeah but dizzy
definitely got fined a few times it all
makes sense like strange music is ran
obviously by tech but by travis and
travis has a rule book like what's with
the iron fist a 30-page rule book of all
this different stuff and it's like
don't like one of the rules is your
girlfriend can't be on the like can't
ride on the tour bus to the next city
well the reason why that's the rule is
because somebody's girlfriend was on the
bus got into it with a rapper and got
her ass knocked out so that's why
there's a reason why there's a rule or
like the reason why fans can't be on the
bus is because a fan came on the bus and
and one of their homies came and shot at
him or whatever and that's why that's a
there's there's a reason for every rule
there's a reason for every rule why you
can't bring weed on the bus why you
can't do this why you can't do that and
you get fined it's like you get fined
the first time you get fined the second
time and the third time you get kicked
off the tour did you get fined at all i
didn't get fined my dj got fined for i
think missing bus call
and
maybe being late to something and then i
know dizzy got fined for smoking in the
green room like eight times and uh that
was pretty much the extent of our buses
fines but
yeah people get fined for a lot of crazy
stuff and it's it's dope though because
for me it's like i didn't have to do
nothing it was the easiest tour ever
because i'm used to doing everything
right right they're handling everything
i just showed up and it's like they got
their own sound tech they got the merch
they got the merch they got a very
organized schedule it's like cool be
here for meet and greet be here for
soundcheck be here for the show
were you allowed to do your crowd dunk
on on that tour because i feel like yeah
you were allowed to do it yeah and that
was actually when i had i told them i'm
like i have to do this this is part of
my show because they don't crowd surf
right and i'm like trust me i'm not like
jumping in the crowd where nobody knows
and the reason why that's the rule is
because somebody got paralyzed at a tech
show from tech surfing [ __ ] so um or
maybe somebody else was surfing somebody
was surfing at a tech show got paralyzed
so for me though i was like look i'm my
thing i'm all in 155 pounds i i hurdle
everybody up i jump in a specific area
never hurt anybody before in my life
i got to do this and yeah they let me do
it
what is something that you learned uh
from from like obviously you've been
around hops hopson a lot but just torn
with tech9 text like professionalism and
like you said like you said just kind of
the professional
like way that strange does business is
very unhip-hop-like yeah i think that
was the coolest thing to me was like i
kind of have a compound in arizona
that's like i got my crib i got uh
my my studio house next door i have a
bunch of stuff going on with ryan from
guest list so like i have my businesses
but theirs bro like you could eat off
the floor at any of their facilities
like
anything like all their facilities are
so clean everything is immaculate
everything is just in pristine condition
so like the way that their operation
worked was really dope to see that
that's probably the illest thing that i
took away from it was just like the
organization and the cleanliness of how
their ship ran right